there are some of the most vulnerable
people in society in need of the
greatest care we have been told he
doesn't belong to us is not our son but
thousands of those with a severe
learning disability and autism are being
failed they were making me into to
utilize locked in hospitals miles from
home that they can't leave even when
they're no longer ill three four five
people would jump on Emma and miss Raine
abandoned them into seclusion it is
barbaric it's Victoria it's time it
ended this is the story of an unseen
unheard generation trapped in care Tony
is 41 he has profound learning
disabilities and autism
[Music]
and he celebrated his last 17 birthdays
in a secure Hospital almost 100 miles
from his parents home in Brighton we
protected his identity because he's been
sectioned under the Mental Health Act
and his parents can't give us permission
to identify him even though they'd like
to
he went into residential care when his
parents worried about what would happen
to him as they got older ya asked for
help
he was only meant to stay nine months
before moving into a home in the
community but he's been trapped ever
since Roy and Pam say that during his
first 10 years in the hospital he was
regularly restrained sedated and
received injuries including a broken arm
they were told he sustained in a fall
his fingers were black and blue
yayoi-san strode on he was being held
down face down but about eight or nine
people we actually see them doing
witness that the witness one of them
holding him down prone following the
incidents Tony was moved to his own
annex but Roy and Pam say he sometimes
isolated and that the years have taken
their toll he's deteriorated a lot he's
uh he doesn't do the same things he used
to do to zoo I mean one we used to go
down there in other places used to say
to Pam you've got a nice dress on Ewing
I like you everybody he takes no notice
now it's just all these interested
really is what you're gonna bring him
what food you're gonna play Tony is in a
low-security hospital run by a private
care company they say all his injuries
were properly investigated and took
place before they owned the hospital
they also say patients are not isolated
but those who need their own living
space receive attention from dedicated
staff and have access to common areas
with other patients Roy and Pam have
been trying to get Tony moved to his own
home
the appropriate community care for years
when we first met they've been told it
might happen by Christmas hopefully
they're gonna get this right because me
and more complicated the skin this is
the end of their loins we have been told
he doesn't belong to us he's not a son
he's not our son we I gave birth to him
and we are parents mates belong to us
belongs to stay you feel powerless you
you can't do nothing it's not Tony on
the edge of a cliff and you can't get
old of him he's there but you can't you
can't get him that's how it feels
Tony and thousands like him are hidden
out of sight and out of mind often for
years in institutions known as
assessment and treatment units or 80 use
they're designed for short-term care of
people with a range of learning
disabilities and are supposed to be
discharged within 18 months in fact the
average length of stay is five and a
half years and the government is about
to break its promise to close up to half
of the beds by next March there are
currently two thousand three hundred and
fifteen people in 80 use in England just
80 fewer than there were in March 2015
when there were two thousand three
hundred and ninety five sixty percent of
them have been admitted for more than
two years and 16% for more than a decade
the number of reported cases of
restraint has risen from sixteen
thousand six hundred and sixty in 2016
to 28 thousand eight hundred and eighty
last year and Sky News has obtained
figures that show 40 patients have died
while admitted to an 80 you since 2015
and nine of the deceased were under 35
four years ago so Stephen love wrote a
progress report on the bed closure
program he was shocked by our figures
and says the government has no excuse to
act
there are deaths of people in these
institutions some of them unexplained we
know there are significant problems
there will be at some stage another
scandal and yet we know what we need to
do the idea that in the 21st century you
lock people up you restrain them prone
restraint you hold them down I think is
disgusting it's barbaric and it is
unacceptable and needs to be made
unlawful to see the difference that
community care can make we came to
Norwich to visit a project run by and
for people with a learning disability
and make sure they got the right support
to keep out the hospital
everyone here has spent time in a secure
Hospital but all are now in community
care with greater control over their
lives and finding their voices Haley
spent more than five years in secure
hospitals I fell into two sliced so when
I came out to live in the community I
was doing a lot of bad things to try and
get myself back into hospital I felt
because I felt safe that's where my
safety net was having the right support
you can achieve there for anything but
it's gotta be the right support for you
and that can take time it can it can
take time to get the right support Ricki
now lives in his own flat and has just
got married but it has been a long road
if I was given to the community and
there would have been good communication
the right support I think I wouldn't
have been in hospital as long as I did
yeah ten years
Fairey how do you feel about that now
that you're living your own life outside
hospitals in a way it makes me angry
that no one helped me to get out earlier
but in a funny way it's whatever
therapies they've done with me and
Medicaid
should have given me now has improved my
life the benefits of community care are
obvious here but one of the reasons
people can get trapped in care is
financial if someone with a learning
disability is in an assessment and
treatment unit the NHS ultimately picks
up the bill that can run to several
hundred thousand pounds a year per
person and often goes to a private
provider once they move into the
community though local authorities have
to pay and Social Care budgets are
already under huge strain perversely
there can be a financial disincentive to
moving people out of hospital and into
their own home
I'm a bit nervous
but I'm really pleased all right George
[Music]
[Music]
George is just beginning that transition
this is the first time he's been to his
mum's house in 18 months just three
weeks earlier he was discharged from a
secure Hospital three four five people
would jump on him and restrain him and
then put him into seclusion as far as
surety is concerned as soon as you lay a
hand on him you're you know in his space
he doesn't like it his autistic doesn't
like being touched he's got a like an
exclusion zone around him and go
straight in he felt that he was being
attacked so he fought back he now lives
nearby in his own home with three carers
24 hours a day I have a lot of
confidence in the team we have excellent
communication that they're talking to me
every single day and I can now I can
talk to them every single day which is
really good and it's all the details
exactly what Georgie is about and who he
is and what he enjoys what he doesn't
enjoy picking up all of the details all
of the time and it's constantly changing
George has personal support from a
dedicated team but he's still on average
six times cheaper to look after people
at home than in a hospital it's about
you know accepting and understanding
that he's got a right to do whatever he
wants to do but at the same time with a
duty of care you need to to make sure
that what he's doing safe and and you
know easy allowed to live a fuller life
as he can that was really quite lifting
Nicola and George and the first people
we've met since we started this who are
smiling and it's clear that with the
right planning the right committed staff
and the right attitude it is possible to
provide eastern care in the community
it's early days for George but it seems
to be working
mistress all his clothes that I've got
already photonics through two mouths
which I thought was
couldn't be moved and he was going in
about fortnight Chuck is gonna be there
never here for Pam and Roy the struggle
goes on they have just heard bad news he
thinks he's having a Christmas with with
a Christmas tree you can imagine not
having a Christmas yes in height one in
21 years no Christmas tree no
decorations where he is all he's got is
a better telly in a chair it's just
another guy they've been told Tony will
not be leaving hospital after all after
a disagreement with Roy and Pam over his
care plan the care provider has
withdrawn its offer of a home near
Brighton that means they'll still be
taking the 200 mile round trip to visit
him every week Brighton & Hove City
Council say they are sympathetic to
Toni's situation but his current
accommodation is the closest to home
that meets his needs they say his
situation is regularly independently
reviewed and hoped to move him to
bespoke accommodation that keeps him and
his carers safe as soon as possible it
is a complex process which can only
proceed with the full confidence of
Tony's parents and the council say
they're restarting the commissioning
process with immediate effect the
Department of Health say they are
committed to supporting people in the
community and that restraint should only
be used as a last resort NHS England so
there are 20% fewer people in 80 use
than three years ago and they're
investing more than 75 million pounds in
moving patients into their own homes
those promises feel like a distant hope
to families torn apart by the care
system
I just felt we've lost him
he went away where it took him away he's
gone
the goal in our family it's just
somebody we'll talk about in a picture
[Music]
you
[Music]